hola lo que quiero que veamos en este
vídeo es el área debajo de la curva de
la función
igual a 1 sobre x cuadrada y cuando x es
igual a 1 podemos ver que es el límite
inferior y que no tenemos un límite
superior
simplemente continuaremos por aquí hasta
infinito cuando x se vaya aproximando
hacia infinito así que lo importante
será visualizar cuál es toda esta área
que estoy coloreando de amarillo y una
forma en cómo podemos hacer esto es con
la definición de integral impropia y
nosotros sabemos cuál es el límite
inferior pero como dijimos iremos por
aquí hasta alcanzar un límite superior
por tanto es el límite vamos a decir que
es infinito y esta es la integral de un
infinito de nuestra función 1 sobre x
cuadrada de x ahora déjame ser clara
esto que tenemos por aquí es una
integral impropia ahora podrás
preguntarte cómo podemos resolver dicha
integral impropia bien pues esto sería
lo mismo que tener el límite cuando n el
límite cuando n se aproxima a infinito
de la integral de 1
de la función 1 sobre x cuadrada de x y
si ves esto es padre porque nosotros
sabemos que esta es la distancia del
intervalo de 1 a n y nosotros ya sabemos
cómo resolver los límites de cuando n se
aproxima a infinito ahora sí viendo cómo
podemos realizar esto sería con el
segundo teorema fundamental del cálculo
la segunda parte de este título nos dice
que esto que tenemos aquí déjame primer
escribir la parte del límite esto es el
límite de cuando n tiende a infinito y
bueno esta parte es el límite y entonces
ahora visualizando en cuanto al segundo
teorema fundamental del cálculo donde
evaluaremos la n en toda la integral de
1 sobre x cuadrada que es lo mismo que
tener x a la menos 2 y al realizar dicha
integral tendríamos que es menos x a la
menos uno pero por estética matemática
dejémoslo más claro y entonces sería lo
mismo que tener menos 1 sobre x así que
esa es la integral de 1 sobre x cuadrada
y vamos a evaluar la de 1
y esto va a ser igual al límite cuando n
se aproxima a infinito y ahora sigue
evaluando dichos extremos de nuestra
integral tendríamos que esto es igual a
tener menos 1 sobre n luego el menos de
la resta del intervalo 1 sobre 1 que es
igual a tener a menos 1 y entonces ahora
hay que encontrar el límite cuando en
ese aproximada de infinito de todo esto
y esta cosa que tenemos por aquí es lo
mismo que tenemos por acá donde no había
encontrado el límite aún por lo que va a
ser igual al límite cuando n se aproxima
a infinito de esto es más 1 y este es el
menos 1 y vamos a acomodar lo primero el
término positivo menos 1 sobre n y
afortunadamente para nosotros el límite
de hecho existe el límite de cuando en
esa próxima a infinito de 1 sobre n este
término va a ser cercano a temer y esto
como 0 pues 1 sobre un término muy
es como tener cero entonces este límite
es igual a 1 y lo que estamos probando
es que esta área que no tiene el límite
superior que simplemente sigue y sigue
siempre está cerca de tener un área
finita que de hecho con lo que hemos
probado es exactamente igual a 1 así que
en este caso tuvimos una integral
impropia porque de hecho nosotros fuimos
capaces de evaluarla llegar a un número
pues de hecho el límite existió entonces
estamos diciendo que nuestra integral
impropia está convergiendo y si por
cualquier razón esto estuviera ilimitado
y no pudiéramos admitir una especie de
número finito aunque realizamos
operaciones estaría diciendo que diverge